[Applause]
uh my next guest really needs no
introduction ladies and gentlemen yoko
ono
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much for being here
i never met you before i've always
wanted to meet you well i've never met
you either so uh that makes two of us
you didn't say you always wanted to meet
me though you left that part out yoko
i'm very reserved now very reserved okay
let's just pretend that you're a huge
fan uh
yeah yeah please settle down i know this
is very exciting for you
well you're finally meeting me you're
taller than me aren't you yes i am i'm
very tall and uh in person much taller
than people think well you don't look
like a part of the human race or
anything you look
more like a tree or something
i have a lot of respect for you yoko so
i okay
i'll restrain myself what do you mean i
don't look like i'm in the human race
you said i look like a tree or something
well you mean that in a nice way a sexy
tall tree no uh yes of course you do yes
of course yes thank you i'm going to
rewrite everything
it was meant to be a compliment because
human race is not always very popular
these days
um well with humans it's still going
strong
okay okay the whales are angry with us i
know
i know but no i will take it as a
compliment it's very nice to have you
here very nice to have you here and you
know what it's it's it's our timing is
impeccable you have gone through a real
resurgence lately they're playing your
music remixed in dance clubs now young
people are going crazy for it that must
be very uh very nice for you part of
them yes oh you are well
yes yes uh well but it must be very that
must be very uh gratifying for you
that's true yes i'm very very thankful i
don't know what your opinion is but my
personal feeling is that in 1970 when
the beatles broke up people were so
angry about that fact they were so angry
that there were a lot of people who
became angry with you they needed to
blame somebody i don't think people
could judge your work honestly for a
long time because they had all these
other emotions do you think that's fair
you have a great opportunity today to
experience it experience what all right
i'll show you okay we're just gonna uh
do
one of the performances together i was
told you want to do something and i
wasn't told what it was uh-huh and now
i'm wishing someone had told me
now what what what are we what are we
going to do
we're going to get into the bag
you and i are going to get into that bag
you don't have to take everything off
oh wait what
you don't have to take everything off
yet
i assumed we were doing this naked
not yet all right
i thought you were out there this is
sril l7 if you ask me okay you get in
first i get in first this is a real bag
this is so cool these are real bags yeah
well i remember
so i get in here yes and i get in first
i have trust issues will i be able to
get out of the bag if i need to you have
to uh you know start trusting the human
race okay all right but i'm not in the
human race according to you well
all right here we go i have no idea why
i got into television okay
uh all right i'm in the bag
oh my god it's incredible in here
i'm here with you
this is great
see we can't see there but they can't
see us that's the idea so the idea is
they can't see us and we can't see them
no we can see them oh we can kind of see
them a little bit yeah i know that's a
good looking crowd by the way now uh
[Applause]
[Music]
i know you're a conservative person so
i'm not going to ask you to take
everything off i would like to know
what you're willing to take off and
don't don't tell them what do you mean
i know but what i'm saying is just
whisper whisper into your ear yes yes
but don't shout in my ear i will not
shout in your ear man yoko's pushing me
around
okay you just whispered in my ear what
we're gonna do all right no no no i
didn't okay oh yeah
all right so we're gonna just take some
stuff off right now okay
we're taking things off and this is i
guess some kind of trust thing each time
each time you have to put it
out what's that you have to sort of like
oh you just throw it out like this
okay
all right i i want to go further then
i i really do yoko i want to go
i want to go further
i can yeah all right i i have more to
give america
and yoko okay i think my mic is coming
off oh yoko
[Applause]
okay hold on a second oh my god
i look good
all right you know what i love anyone
tuning in right now doesn't know what's
happening
well they have good imagination
huh
okay all right you go first yoko
or should i go first me first i think
you have to take me first and kind of
take it let's take the socks off
yoko you don't want me to take the socks
off
i played soccer this morning and then
didn't shower no you have to you have to
go out first i go first okay
wait a minute
i totally got screwed here i had to take
everything off and you didn't take uh
can i wear your job
try yoko's jacket just for a second and
then just see
well
yoko that was all our time i had all
these cool questions i was going to ask
you yes and well you still made it up
like this
so we really know we had yoko ono on the
show give her a big hand everybody
you